Rockets are magnificent engineering feats that
have allowed us to travel into space and orbit
over the past several decades. But, though rockets
are extremely cool, they cost massive amounts of
money and carry substantial risk during each
flight. In contrast, we have our other flying
masterpiece: the airplane. Not only can airplanes
also fly, but they’re astronomically cheaper and
more reliable than rockets. In fact, the annual
risk of an American being killed in an airplane
crash is only 1 in 11 million. To put that into
perspective, Nasa estimates that there’s a 1 in
276 chance of a Falcon 9 disaster leading to loss
of life. That means that one of the most reliable
rockets of all time is still 40,000 times riskier
than your average plane. But let’s be real here,
I’m sure the brainiacs working at space agencies
around the world have already considered this. So,
why can’t planes just fly into space? Well,
to answer this question, we have to first
understand the physics behind how airplanes fly
in the first place. While it may seem like the
powerful engines on planes are doing all the work
in keeping us airborne, this is actually not true.
In fact, the engines on airplanes are quite
weak in comparison to the maximum capacity of
the plane. The ratio between the force generated
by a plane’s engines and the gravitational force
pulling down the airplane is called the thrust to
weight ratio. And you’ll be surprised to hear how
low these ratios really are. The Boeing 747-8
only has a thrust to weight ratio of 0.269,
and the largest passenger aircraft, the airbus
a380, only has a thrust to weight ratio of 0.227.
The thrust to weight ratios of most
commercial aircraft land between 0.2 and 0.35.
Even the concorde, which was a supersonic
commercial aircraft, only has a thrust to
weight ratio of 0.372. But, if airplane engines
are only generating enough thrust to lift a fifth
to a third of the plane's maximum weight, how
is the plane even able to gain altitude? Well,
this is where extremely clever engineering of
the wings comes into play. The underside of an
airplane’s wings are flat while the topside of the
airplane’s wings are rounded. This means that air
flowing on the top side of the wing has to travel
a further distance than the air on the bottom side
of the wing. The total volume of air flowing on
either side of the wing, however, is the same. So,
the air on the top side of the wing is spread over
a larger area than the air on the bottom side of
the wing. This difference causes the top side of
the wing to have a lower pressure than the bottom
side of the wing. Given that particles naturally
want to move from high pressure to lower pressure,
the wing naturally wants to move upwards, and
this force is called lift. If we’re able to
create a large enough pressure difference between
two sides of the wings, the generated lift will
be greater than the gravitational force pulling
down the airplane, and that’s the secret behind
how airplanes actually gain altitude. Over the
past several decades, engineers have basically
perfected every single component of the plane
from bending the tips of wings to utilizing flaps.
All of these efforts have one goal in mind,
maximize lift and minimize fuel consumption.
While this has made airplanes insanely efficient,
it has also made them extremely dependent on air.
Without air, most of our planes wouldn’t
leave the ground. But what if we just put
more powerful engines onto our planes or made
the planes themselves smaller. If we could get
the thrust to weight ratio to be greater than
1, airplanes wouldn’t need lift to gain altitude
right? Well, that’s true, and we actually have
a bunch of fighter jets that do have a thrust to
weight ratio that’s greater than 1. The F-15, for
instance, has a ratio of 1.04 and the F-22 has a
ratio 1.09 which can even be increased to 1.26
with the right combination of fuel and payload.
This is why these jets can do vertical takeoffs,
loops, barrel rolls, and who knows what else. But
just because these jets are not dependent on
lift doesn’t mean that they aren’t dependent
on air. And that brings me into the fundamental
difference between rocket engines and jet engines.
Both engines use combustion and Newton’s third
law to create thrust, but if you think about it,
you’d quickly realize that a jet engine
has both in intake and an exhaust
while rocket engines only have an exhaust. Jet
engines have an intake because they rely on the
oxygen in the air for combustion. Without a steady
intake of oxygen, combustion can’t take place,
and the jet engines simply won't work. Now, it’s
not like rocket engines are any better. Rocket
engines also need oxygen to work, and this is
why we have solid and liquid rocket propellant.
In a solid fuel rocket, the fuel and oxidizer
is mixed together into a chemical and engines
simply use the chemical during flight. With
liquid fuel rockets, the fuel and the oxidizer
are actually stored separately and the engines
combine the two ingredients during combustion.
But either way, both jet and rocket
engines need oxygen to operate,
and since jet’s don’t carry oxygen along
with them, they can’t just fly into space.
So, the bottom line is basically just a lack of
atmosphere in space. Planes need the atmosphere
to generate lift and they need the oxygen
in the atmosphere to fire up their engines.
If the atmosphere didn’t thin out as we reach
space, planes should theoretically be able to fly
anywhere in the solar system, though it would be
a rather slow mode of transport. But, since that’s
not the case, airplanes have a service ceiling
which is generally around 42 to 43,000 feet.
What if we just strapped rocket engines to
airplanes though, as long as the thrust to weight
ratio is greater than 1, the aircraft would
no longer be dependent on the atmosphere.
People have actually had this idea for nearly a
hundred years at this point with the first rocket
powered flight dating back to the early 1900s.
In 1928 a German plane the Lippisch Ente became
the first aircraft to fly using rocket power. A
couple of years later in 1931, an Italian aviator
named Ettore Cattaneo built the first privately
built rocket plane. We also saw several rocket
powered aircraft throughout World War 2, but it
wasn’t until the cold war that we actually tried
to use this technology to reach space. The most
notable spaceplane attempt of all time was likely
the North American X-15. The X-15 was proposed
way back in December of 1954 which was before
Nasa even existed, so the plane was to be built by
North American Aviation and Reaction Motors. The
plan was to carry the X-15 on a mother ship called
the B-52 to an altitude of 8.5 miles at a speed
of 500 miles per hour. At this point, the B-52
would release the X-15, and the X-15 would use two
liquid propellant rocket engines to fly as high
as possible. Fortunately, the X-15 actually made
it past the concept board, and the first rocket
powered flight would take place on September 17,
1959. Over the next decade the various
versions of the X-15 would be flown 199 times.
Fun fact, one of the pilots of the X-15 was Neil
Armstrong. Anyway, in 1963, pilot Joe Walker would
successfully fly the plane past 100 km in altitude
which meant that the X-15 could officially reach
space. But, aside from technically reaching space,
the X-15 couldn’t actually complete anything
meaningful in space. It couldn’t reach orbit and
it was nowhere near escape velocity of mach 33.
But, nonetheless, the plane was extremely
impressive as it could reach mach 6 or 4000 mph,
and it was a great first step in developing a
plane that could actually travel into space.
After the X-15 program came to a close, Nasa
decided to basically develop a hybrid space
plane with the space shuttle. The idea was to
launch like a rocket but land like a plane,
but this is when Nasa would run into by far the
largest obstacle when it comes to space planes
and that’s excessive heat. Though the
X-15 was an extremely fast aircraft,
it could only reach 1/5th the speed of
escape velocity. Speeding up the aircraft
to escape velocity was extremely hard, but that
wasn’t the main obstacle. The main problem was
that it was and still is nearly impossible to
handle the generated heat. But wait a minute,
we have rockets that go way faster than the X-15,
so how are they able to handle the heat? Well,
that’s the reason that rockets launch vertically
at least at the start. The idea is to get the
rocket as high as possible before it reaches
extreme velocities. At these higher altitudes,
the atmosphere will be much thinner which heavily
reduces the generated heat. The easy solution to
this problem would be to just launch the space
plane vertically, and that’s basically what
Nasa settled on with the Space Shuttle. At that
point, it’s more of a rocket than a space plane,
but even after doing this, Nasa faced major
heat problems when it came to reentry.
The underside of the space shuttle had a total
of 20,548 heat shield tiles, and every single
tile had to be individually inspected after every
single flight. Even a small amount of damage to
these heat shield tiles could lead to catastrophic
results like we saw with Columbia. So, truthfully,
Nasa never figured out an efficient way to refly
the Space Shuttle, and this was one of the biggest
downfalls of the space shuttle. Considering this,
Nasa should’ve never tried to make a full on space
plane until they figured out a more efficient
solution for the Space Shuttle, but nonetheless,
Nasa started to work on a single stage to
orbit space plane called the X-30 in the 1980s.
The plane was slated to have top speeds of Mach 25
and it seemed like the plane would be straight out
of movie. That should’ve been a major red flag
though as the plane was way too overambitious.
According to Nasa engineer Ivan Bekey, the X-30
was “the biggest swindle ever to be foisted on the
country” and it “was full of dubious aerodynamic
claims and engine performance claims and thermal
claims.” Basically, Nasa had nowhere near
enough technology to make the plane a reality,
and the $1.7 billion invested into the project
was a complete waste. Nasa didn’t give up after
the X-30 though. Later on, they started working
on the X-43 which did reach production and it
was able to achieve a top speed of Mach 9.6.
But even that isn't nearly enough to reach
orbit using a space plane. In the meantime, the
overarching space community has come to a broad
conclusion. What’s even the point of trying
to solve this nearly impossible heat problem
with space planes when we can just keep using
traditional rockets and continue exploring space.
At the end of the day, who cares if the
vehicle launches vertically or horizontally,
the destination is what really matters. Though
it would be super cool to fly a plane into space,
it really doesn’t pose any additional benefits.
Originally, many scientists thought that space
planes were the key to reusability and cheap
launch costs. But, SpaceX is proving that these
attributes can be achieved using traditional
rockets, so the excitement around space planes
is more or less dying off. Maybe a hundred years
from now after we’ve mastered traditional rockets,
we’ll see space planes make a
comeback. But in the meantime,
it makes no sense to try to battle with the laws
of physics when you can just launch vertically.
Would you prefer to ride in a space plane or a
traditional rocket? Comment that down below. Also,
drop a like if you thought this video explained
the physical limitations of space planes well.
And of course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see
more questions logically answered.